hello ma'am the dogs will be fine right
now
he's right there
okay he's right there
I need I'm gonna grab that dog
[Applause]
yep come on
hey buddy
it's okay buddy come here come here
no no no don't cut it don't cut it
yeah
it's okay Jesus
you get it come on
it's okay
it's okay buddy
Robert
let me try to do it hold him just hold
him
down bring them down
I know
[Applause]
let's go
away come on I got him come on boy
come on I got you I got you come on come
on come on
come on
hello y'all
no
hey hey
[Applause]
let you go down
come on
[Applause]
so I need to go
well we just want to get here take these
guys with you
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a good place come on
[Applause]
get in get him get your dog
let's go for a ride come on come on come
on get in come on
[Music]
[Applause]
it's good turkey come on here come on
okay
let's go down there
you go over here come on
the chihuahua named Tinkerbell uh him
and his owner fell in the water off a
boat uh without you you're over at
you'll probably see uh where my lights
are so he fell in
with the dogs been in the water for
about 40 minutes so the Chihuahua
Tinkerbell
all right I'm just gonna check along
these docks here
um and then you know if I see birds on
lines I know the dog hasn't been over
there
so yeah so okay all right let's check
over here
all right
[Music]
foreign
come over here
62-61 5-12 would Tinkerbell Tinkerbell
fuck up
hey uh
Tinkerbell
I hope you don't bite
Tinkerbell come on pop up
Tinkerbell
hey Tinkerbell one dispatch that's uh
Gone lovely name for chihuahua I hope
you're nice
36 in Goodrich hey puppies
it's okay puppy
it's okay Tinkerbell
hey Tinkerbell
hey Tinkerbell oh come on girl hey
Tinkerbell hey Tinkerbell
hey Tinkerbell what are you doing what
are you doing Tinkerbell
girl it's okay
it's okay puppy
puppy
come on come on girl
come on
it's okay
all right
[Applause]
it's okay
yeah Tinkerbell is healthy
yes will you watch my boat
we have a swimmer yeah someone fell off
their boat with Tinkerbell
Tinkerbell has been found
truck
good yep all right let's watch my whip
poor little dog that's crazy
y'all found him just
um the guy fell off his boat
is he in the water still yeah all right
man that's amazing
what was he hanging on how are you hey
good good I saw you I was like gosh I I
said man my neighbors are uh we're out
late tonight all right did you man did
you guys have to come in uh no we were
just doing a anchor lights
no no I'll tell you where they're voted
okay
oh my God
[Laughter]
well we just started looking we got the
call and Tinkerbell was hunkered on a
little piece of floating wood underneath
the dog
okay look right here
all right yeah
um I'm sure Tinkerbell is ready to see
Mom and Dad oh okay no he's
kisses
um
just leaving them by yourself no no no
we're gonna take him with us we'll okay
I just wanted I can't tell you how about
that all right I'm glad right glad she's
okay
this is just unbelievable we were just
looking and looking and looking yeah I
like that you're right
he looks a little angry
hey
the dorm is panting and drooling all
over the place but it's a pickle so I
didn't want to break it before you got
here oh my God he's starting to go down
yeah that's not good
it's starting to go down
all right so do you want to get
something that we can because I don't
know if he's going to attack or not so
yeah I tried the doors and they tried
and they don't know whose car this is
they don't know whose car it is it's not
coming back to anybody so I think we
should break it at least get some
airflow through there yeah
okay hey open the back window back
window Maybe do we have um because he's
going down which is not good you know
yeah yeah
which side you want to break it off no I
mean he's on that side right now let's
break this up you need a towel to break
it with or no you just break it like
that
break it like that
it's a good Barrel you're a good boy
go ahead man
okay
buddy yeah he's drooling so yeah well I
mean he's breathing
come on
good boy
well wait I don't want to get away I
don't want to get away
all right come on buddy
that's a good boy
you got the water I gave you yeah
come on
boys
looks like she's bleeding now
this is the door already open it's 1 15.
115 Matt
115.
this poor thing
foreign
excellent
good job
almost there
[Applause]
oh I forgot sakes
morning
oh my goodness
only you poor thing
I almost got you
oh my God this is tight up tight
here you've been
there you go
swimming
thank you for letting it do this
or maybe physically just don't have
good choice
no stabbing me come on calm down you're
fine sweetie
good good job you're good yeah
okay you're just making things worse
right yeah it's free here sweetie you're
fine here all right yeah come here
you need to calm down
come on buddy
[Applause]
all right you gotta calm
you're fine calm now you're stuck you
keep getting stuck
stop all right
hold on
okay that's fine
you're doing good good job go go all
right yeah that's where they usually go
hey is everybody out
where's the cat where's
420 everybody's out
where do you think your cat was
I don't know
[Music]
come here kitty kitty
come here kitty kitty kitty
[Music]
cats probably keep your down low
we gotta find the cat
[Music]
where you at
what about
oh man
I gotta step out for a minute
[Music]
you got it upstairs too
ah
okay
she says up the stairs and to the right
now that's where it's hiding at yeah
possibly is there a staircase over here
all right we got
you got something
[Music]
watch out Jesus you want to move
you're accomplishing this cat there we
go
there we go
foreign